foreign
[Music]
welcome to the interval and long now I'm
Alexander Rose the executive director
here at longnow this is the very first
uh
kind of pilot of a fellowship program
that we are working on for the future
with long now and we've spent the last
25 26 years in a way bringing people to
us to talk out towards you
but the next 25 years we're trying to
find people in their own communities
that are doing very interesting work in
long-term thinking that
can create their own spaces and their
own communities and do that and so this
is the very first version of that with
that
please join us Alicia Eggert
thank you so much Xander and thank you
all for being here I just want to say
that this is such a huge honor I can't
believe I am speaking to some of the
people in this room so thank you thank
you so much
laughs
okay so as a conceptual artist I have
always gravitated to language as a
material I like to think I sculpt words
the way that other sculptors work with
wood or stone and the reason I like to
use language and give words tangible
physical forms and space is because I
believe we might be able to understand
an idea more fully if we can experience
it physically not only do I use language
to express meaning I also take advantage
of the way that meaning can be embedded
in a material and the way that each
material I work with has its own
duration or lifespan and I explore
everything from cut flowers to welded
steel which is a much more kind of
traditional sculpture material
and meaning is also embedded in the
processes I choose to use so for
instance sculpting additively is much
different than sculpting subtractively
and in this example the word future
because it's removed from a larger form
becomes a negative space or a void I
also love the way that viewing sculpture
is a very embodied experience the work
inhabits your physical space and you can
walk around it and see it from multiple
perspectives and your individual
perspective as a viewer really matters
actually it helps to shape the work's
meaning and in this case it you know
determines the way you see the future
because my work is text-based I'm
naturally drawn to using the materials
and strategies that are often used in
commercial signage so I'm inspired by
all kinds of signs including road signs
and like reflective vinyl and the colors
that are used in those and I'm drawn to
the material and the medium of neon for
all the obvious reasons you know nothing
compares to that quality of light
emitted by electrified gases that are
trapped in a you know glass tube but
neon is also actually very sculptural
the glass tubes are heated and bent over
a flame and they're often bent back on
themselves in order to create a specific
shape but my favorite thing about neon
signs is animating them and the way it
allows me to bring them to life
literally and the flashing is obviously
designed to sort of grab your attention
but I also like to use it to create a
specific rhythm in the work the pace is
intentionally slow and enough so that
you can read The Works messages but it's
also fast enough to hold your attention
and keep you present and also make you
aware of times passing it's similar for
me to like the rhythm of breath in
mindfulness meditation
my desire to give time a tangible
physical form actually started with this
project that I did in graduate school I
called it the length of now and when I
did a Google search of that term is when
I discovered the long now foundation and
became a member I think it was like 2008
but this project involved cutting pieces
of red yarn to really specific lengths
and then soaking them in water and then
freezing them into the shape of the word
now and then taking them out of the
freezer and hanging them on a nail on a
wall and then allowing them to melt and
I made videos of those Nows melting
because each one was unique right and I
projected my favorite video onto the
wall with a clock in order to juxtapose
our lived experience of time with our
perception of time and also with that
sort of measured mechanical clock time
and this video of now that I chose
really highlighted for me how our
awareness of time passing is linked to
our perception of motion
so there were long moments where the
word appears static and change is like
pretty imperceptible and time feels slow
and really stretched and then when you
begin to perceive the motion you have
this heightened sense of anticipation of
something just about to happen and then
in moments of more abrupt change time
seems to speed up right and it was
interesting also to try to identify at
which point the word now was no longer
now but no or nothing at all my
fascination with time probably stems
from the fact that my dad was a pastor
so I was raised in church and I was
constantly reminded of the inevitability
of my death and the possibility of an
eternal afterlife right instead of
believing in an afterlife I ended up
becoming an atheist and I'm much more
inclined to believe something the
philosopher Ludwig Wittgenstein said
which is that eternal life belongs to
those that live in the present and since
the definition of Eternity is
timelessness what better material is
there to create it than Clocks by Nature
the motion of clock hands is cyclical
and potentially infinite the minute hand
goes around once every hour and the hour
hand goes around once every 12 hours and
it's only then that we see this word
eternity that video is high speed you
know time lapse but when you actually
experience this work in person you
perceive it as a static object so the
you know the motion of those minute
hands is just on the limits of our
perception and in contrast to that sort
of cyclical mechanical time the reality
of our lived experience of time is very
linear and finite and I'm drawn to the
ways in which we measure that kind of
time in our daily lives like with the
height charts that we keep on the walls
of our houses when our children are
growing up so this one on the screen is
actually inspired by my own son's height
chart he's eight years old now and last
year I actually asked him you know how
tall do you think you're going to be
when you grow up and I asked him to
point to that spot on the wall and I
drew a line there and I wrote someday
and then the height that he was at that
exact moment became now and then all the
moments before are then
and it's interesting to think about how
when we're children we count time up but
then at a certain point when we get
older if we start to count time down and
time becomes ultimately a reminder of
our mortality
um and our hearts are like ticking
clocks
so this is a sculpture that has an
average human lifespan that I called
pulse machine
and the drum is the heart and it beats
its pulse and the counter on the wall
counts down the number of seconds
remaining in the sculpture's lifetime
and it uses those flip digit numerals
from old scoreboards that remind me of
like the ventricles of a heart and the
sculpture is programmed to die when the
counter reaches zero
uh it's a little bit like pose Telltale
Heart kind of reminding us of the
inevitability of death and some people
have told me it's like a little dark or
creepy
um but I actually believe that thinking
about time more deeply and more
regularly encourages us to live more
meaningfully you know it reminds us to
focus on more important things instead
of more urgent things you know and
what's more urgent than death
I actually enjoy putting my work in
public spaces for this very same reason
to give people more opportunities to
think about time deeply in their daily
lives public art allows people to
encounter art in unexpected situations
and in the real world and in real time
and that site-specific experience is
very very different from the experience
that you have with art in a gallery or a
museum which are spaces that are
typically you know designed to be
outside of time they sort of pluck
objects out of the real world sometimes
unethically and put them in these boxes
that often don't even have Windows where
objects are you know preserved for
posterity and a lot of my work as an
artist is actually driven by my desire
to sort of push back against that
expectation that Society has of artists
to make work that will last forever
and the sense of place afforded by a
specific site I think provides context
for The Works message right so and not
just in like a static or a singular way
the work and its meaning are impacted by
continuous changes in the environment in
the light and the atmospheric conditions
the sense of timelessness implied by
this word forever is contrasted by you
know our observable time in the
landscape and it was very much inspired
by that phrase on a clear day you can
see forever right but I love the way
that when fog rolls in it literally
erases everything in sight you know and
I love that the way our perception of
space changes also sort of affects the
way we perceive time
and this way of experiencing art like
out in the real world is not only visual
it engages all of our senses so in this
case the appearance and disappearance of
this word in the fog is coupled with
those crashing waves and the birds
flying by sometimes and those repetitive
blaring fog horns
so one of the wonderful things for me
about light as a medium is the way that
it illuminates everything around it
right so when I place a neon sign in a
specific environment not only does the
site impact the work but the work also
impacts the site and it casts its light
and the color like on everything it can
touch
and in the same way that turning one
little word on and off in a sentence can
dramatically change what that sentence
is communicating
installing the same sign in a very
different place can also completely
change the way that it's interpreted so
being on a remote island like in the
Mediterranean is very different from
being on the island of Manhattan
so I read books for inspiration I
specifically look for books that are
written from the perspective of physics
or philosophy about the way we
understand time and it was just very
natural for me to read Stuart's book The
Clock of the long now when I became a
member of the long now Foundation but
the way that I work is when I'm reading
I like have my notebook nearby and I
write down the quotes or the ideas that
really inspire me and I was captivated
by this quote but I sort of put those
away and put them to the side and then
it's usually many years later when I'm
brainstorming ideas for new work or
creating new work for an exhibition that
I go back through old sketchbooks and
try to look for something that really
jumps out to me in that moment and feels
relevant at that time
so it was actually many many years later
after I read the clock of long now that
I went back through old sketchbooks as I
Was preparing for an exhibition and I
came across the quote and I started to
brainstorm ways I could illuminate it
and animate it and in order to ask for
Stewart's permission to use it I decided
to tweet this rendering at him and
obviously it's a very initial rendering
the sign ended up looking nothing like
this it was my first attempt at how how
what it would look like but I want to
pause
real quick at this point in the story
and talk about the relationship between
possibility and reality because another
one of long now's co-founders Brian Eno
once said that humans are capable of a
unique trick
creating realities by first imagining
them
and I really believe this to be true
actually I also believe that our sense
of possibility is directly correlated to
our conception of time so the more
expansively we think about the here and
now the larger our sense of possibility
and I'm also interested in the
transformation of possibility into
reality when does it switch from you
know only being possible to actually
being real so at this time when I
tweeted at Stuart you know the sign was
still just in the realm of possibility
and I could imagine it but it was very
possible that he would say no or he
would just ignore me altogether right
but if you know Stuart you probably know
that I didn't even need to ask for his
Blessing because he gives it freely so
as you can see here he ended up tweeting
back at me just a few minutes later
literally and he said sure
so this is the first edition of this
present moment that I made for an
exhibition I had in Portugal in 2019 and
as you can see the design changed
dramatically from my initial rendering
because at some point I realized I could
turn off those two words present and
unimaginable and I could reveal another
kind of complete statement this moment
used to be the future and when I
realized that I knew I had to align all
the text on the left hand side so that
when those words disappeared there
wasn't like a gaping hole right in the
design and the color pink was also a
very deliberate choice I take color very
seriously and I chose pink at that time
in 2019 because of the Ripple effects
that the metoo movement was having on
the world I personally was trying to
imagine what the world would look like
if it was more Equitable and more safer
for women and girls and I also wanted to
imagine you know a future where the
color pink wasn't always just associated
with women and girls and it's crazy to
think back on this time because here we
are three years later I never could have
imagined that we'd be living in a
post-row world right but after sharing
that finished work with Stuart again on
Twitter I found out that this quote
actually is co-authored with Stuart's
friend and poet Gary Snyder who wrote
this epigram and shared it with Stuart
inspiring him to write the quote that
inspired me so I really love this
backstory and it's beautiful for me to
see how this sentiment has evolved over
time and how I am now a part of that
Evolution but I make three editions of
each neon sign so that I can share them
with more people in the world and
actually put them more places in the
world later that same year I made a
second edition that ended up being
acquired by the smithsonian's Renwick
gallery and around that same time I
started having conversations with Xander
as he said about where in the world we
could bring this sign that would be a
meaningful place to the organization it
was around that time that I learned
about this property on Mount Washington
in Nevada and the fact that it's the
home to some of the world's longest
living trees the Bristlecone Pines some
of which have lived over 5 000 years
that process of actually imagining what
we were about to do and then making a
reality took about a year and it
involved making a third edition of the
neon sign with my studio assistant Jess
Greene in my studio in Dallas Texas and
I made this sign specifically for this
opportunity the the scale of it and also
the way that it's constructed in modular
components so that it can easily
assemble and disassemble so here you can
see it in the back of a moving truck and
the sign structure is made of steel
right and all of the glass components
are stored in that wood crate
and I just want to take a second to
acknowledge the fact that we use glass
for this specific project because it's
kind of insane
and the most insane part about it is
that I didn't make any backups
so we only had one piece of glass for
each part of the sign and if any of them
broke along the way we would have been
screwed but we probably would have found
ways of making it still happen but that
materiality of glass was actually a
really important part of this project
for me because I think it really speaks
to that fragility of like possibility
reality relationships right and it's
interesting to think about when the
culmination of an idea draws nearer and
we could we've been planning for a year
and we can now really imagine what it's
going to look like on this Mountaintop
but the closer we got to actually making
that a reality the more fragile all that
sense of possibility actually became
because one broken letter could have
like totally made it potentially
impossible
and one of the most significant
challenges as you can see here was
getting the glass up this mountain
safely up to 11 000 feet it's so
interesting to learn about the
Bristlecone Pines and the fact that they
actually thrive in these really extreme
conditions that you can only find at
these you know really high elevations so
it was really interesting to try to make
that Journey up to this place where they
live and of course we had to do all
these crazy switchbacks and the road was
dirt and there was all these huge ruts
and every time we went over a bump I was
freaking out inside
but thankfully I was in really good
hands and I also had like a whole team
of people who were so equipped and like
fully you know acquainted with
installing art projects in really
extreme environments so we arrived at
the Mountaintop around noon and after
lunch we immediately got to work
assembling the signs struck picture and
our goal was to have everything set up
by Sunset and this video for me really
shows how fast that afternoon seemed to
go by and I think it's kind of funny
because it might be the shortest term
project the long now Foundation has ever
done
as you can see we did manage to get the
sign up and working right before the
sunset and I'm so thankful we did
another artist and also along now
research fellow Jonathan Keats something
that he said about this particular
moment was how it allowed us to witness
the simultaneity of so many different
time scales right the flashing on and
off of those words every three seconds
coupled with the passing of the clouds
overhead Gathering and parting and then
the change of the light as the sun set
over the course of about an hour all of
those things were then juxtaposed with
the lifespans the 5 000 year old trees
that were surrounding us right so it was
quite a magical experience
but one thing actually that did not go
according to plan
um was that the electronic flasher that
I typically use to change the states of
those signs that every three seconds
actually didn't work and we couldn't
figure out why we thought it had
something to do with the electricity
coming out of the generator not jiving
with it we couldn't figure it out so
ultimately I had to plug and unplug
these different sections of the neon
sign at this power strip and you can see
in this video how determined I was to
keep that Rhythm really consistent for
me it's so so so important that each
state of the sign lasts three seconds
not four not two three seconds right and
that it repeats over and over and over
again creating that really sort of
meditative experience so when you look
at this video I'm imagine me off to the
right hand side of the scene counting
One Mississippi two Mississippi three
Mississippi
that sort of meditative and very
Mechanical Rhythm of the sign became
kind of like a ticking clock you know
and that was juxtaposed with our own
lived experiences of time and the length
of our own human lifespans
so people really love to photograph the
sign when it's illuminated of course
right but that third state where all the
words turn off for three seconds is
actually really important for me because
from my point of view it actually
returns our attention to the landscape
and this was especially crucial here in
this really epic landscape right the
Basin and Range Province I actually
learned is home to some of the highest
mountain peaks in the contiguous United
States and that elevated perspective is
also an important conceptual component
of this project because I like to think
that shift in perspective that bird's
eye view that we get from a Mountaintop
as being really similar to that broader
perspective of time right seeing that
longer now yet another time scale we can
experience when we look out at that
landscape is the geological time scale
and the time it takes for geological
forces to stretch the Earth's crust and
to form a mountain as the sun set the
Stars began to appear and I don't know
why but for some reason this was very
unexpected you know when you think about
putting any inside on the mountain you
think about like the sunset but I never
could have imagined that the Milky Way
the band of the Milky Way would
literally be right behind it it was
beautiful and this revealed a whole
other time scale that of galaxies and I
didn't actually know until the other day
that our galaxy is spinning did you know
that
and then it takes about 240 million
years to complete one rotation so here
in this one image we have two vastly
different time scales right A present
moment that lasts depending on how you
think of it three seconds or nine
seconds and one that lasts 240 million
years
so what I've always loved about this
quote is the way that we can each relate
to it like on a very individual level
and when we think about this present
moment and how it was once unimaginable
we can think about our current
relationships or the kind of current
state of our career but I also love how
it can also kind of speak to a more
Universal level and things that are
going on in the world that you know
affect all of us I like to think about
how if this present moment was once
unimaginable how it naturally makes you
wonder and want to try to imagine you
know what the future will hold so I
personally
I'm trying to imagine a future of gender
equality of equal pay right and equal
access to abortions wouldn't that be
something but
but I wonder what you are all imagining
for the future I think in moments like
this which we had sort of gazing out at
the world from a Mountaintop or you
could have gazing up at the stars at
night or that feeling you get when
you're standing in front of a work of
art that like really really moves you
that broader perspective that you get
that bird's eye view or that feeling of
awe maybe can give you a new way of
understanding the world right it can
give you that shift in perspective and
it can help you see the bigger here and
the longer now
and the roles that we play in it both
individually and also collectively
and I think that that shift in
perspective can actually help us imagine
otherwise unimaginable Futures and this
was definitely an unimaginable future
for me at some point being able to
stand besides your brand and gaze up at
this sign that I made Illuminating his
words I'm really grateful for this
experience I'm also really grateful to
all of these people who participated in
this project some of whom are not even
pictured here but thank you all for
helping make this moment a reality
and yeah so this was it was such an
amazing project to happen over so many
years and then
the culmination moment of the actual
trip I'm curious as I mean you've done
many projects in many remote places and
where does this fit in the scale of the
things that you have done like that this
was definitely a first for me in many
ways in terms of like the actual
elevation but it's crazy that literally
only two weeks later I took a neon sign
up Kilimanjaro so it was almost like a
sort of a trial run for that other
project which was crazy because this was
like a lifelong goal and then I
immediately had to be like okay great
that went really well now I'm on to this
next thing
um but yeah I think that the the people
that came together to make it happen
like Gary with his truck and Trey and
Scout and all the other people who were
in The Caravan up the mountain I didn't
mention that Gary's truck actually broke
down along the way too and we like held
this
thing together I didn't even know what
it was but we held it together with zip
ties maybe I'm not sure
um but all those people that were able
to come together and make it possible
were definitely like a I think it's a
testament to the organization you know
and the types of people that it attracts
it was just like a magical experience to
be a part of that I see it very much as
a collaboration
our goal with the um yeah doing
something like this fellowship program
is to do things that only
only we could do with a collaboration
like this where you know you know
very few people have a Mountaintop with
Bristlecone Pines on it and very few
people are doing the kind of work that
you're doing and so the idea that it
could come together and be that unique
and you know we don't want to reproduce
other people's Fellowship programs you
want to do something that can be uh only
done in this way so that I think this
was a kind of a perfect example of that
um but I'd love to talk a little bit
about your process you're a conceptual
artist and you work with all kinds of
Artisans and other people to create a
lot of this stuff
um and it's done through a design
process but you're you don't build
everything correct um and so I'd love to
hear you just talk a little bit about
that yeah for sure so
um as a conceptual artist I definitely
love participating in the physical
process and doing whatever it actually
makes sense for me to do in this case my
assistant Jess and I welded the steel
structure and did all of that metal
fabrication and of course the design
that led to that
but I do not Bend glass I am not a neon
bender and that's something that at a
certain point in my career it was
actually in graduate school I went to
Alfred University for my MFA and they
have a neon program within the art
school and I I was in grad school for
two years and I saw that class and I was
like there is no way I'm going to master
that craft in this short amount of time
especially with the things that I want
to do with the medium so if I wanted to
use it almost like as a a drawing tool
then maybe it would have made more sense
but because I knew I wanted to create
really specific things like letter forms
it made more sense for me to actually
call upon people who are experts in that
craft and one of those is actually here
in this audience
Ames who's here is a neon vendor here in
San Francisco
and Ames has helped me with a neon sign
I had at the Exploratorium about a year
ago but Ames is also going to help with
a letter that broke that I discovered
today
broke at some point either in the
de-installation OR transportation from
the Fort Mason back to storage so
um so yeah for me it's actually
um it's it makes the process more
enjoyable for me to not be only doing it
by myself because I actually feel like
that collaboration with other artists
and experts in their fields kind of
makes the the project more successful in
the end but it also makes the process
sort of like it makes that final moment
something that you can celebrate with
like a whole group of people and not
just as like sort of this individual and
I feel like it's something that I'm
really trying to
um
I think in the art World specifically
we're all used to in music or in film
there's always like credits where
everyone who participated in that
project is acknowledged but for some
reason in the art world it's still we
still have this idea that there's this
like one Soul creative genius behind
everything which is definitely hardly
ever the case anymore so it's something
I'd like to to see change I think yeah I
have to say you know as we were doing
this and then you know all the effort
and all the logistics of getting this to
the top of the mountain and not breaking
it and putting it up and and you know
it's a set of words but I think maybe
all of you in the room got a sense of
that when we saw this video it's like it
is so much more than a few words the
moment that it was like I mean I was
crying when it happened and watching the
videos like crying again so it was uh
it's like it's uh it's it's interesting
how how it can be so simple and so
powerful at the same time and it's a
credit to the thought that you put in
into it
um I think you also told me that
sometimes when you go to you've traveled
with some of these signs that they've
broken and then you have to find a local
Artisan to fix them yeah
yeah you are on an island sign I think
is the most well-traveled uh piece that
I've made it was actually made in
collaboration with a former partner
named Mike Fleming one of our friends at
some point was like you know what I
can't believe you made this work you
were on an island you get to go to all
these islands like I should make
something that says you are on a resort
but we do we have we we've gotten the
opportunity to go to a lot of places
because of that sign and actually
there's like a permanent version of it
on the rooftop of a building in St
Petersburg Russia of all places because
it turns out St Petersburg is a series
of islands who knew what's interesting
is so one of the coolest locations we
took you were on an island was Malta for
the malta Arts Festival I think in 2013
and
um it was there that like as I'm putting
one of the letters up on the sign I I
think I just like
did I don't know I tweaked something a
little weird I torqued the glass in a
way that it didn't like and just like
Snapped it and
um but of course again there were no
backups so immediately we were like okay
so who does neon and Malta right
and it turns out there was one neon shop
um in the country
and it was run by a family of three
generations a grandfather a father and a
son that had been doing it for I don't
know how long you know probably close to
how long the medium has even been around
um and so we got to go there you know
bring the broken letter to them so they
could use it to make a pattern and make
a new one and it was just the coolest
experience to meet them and to see their
shop and then at like literally every
single neon person I meet is is so are
there some of the nicest people on the
planet so
um it's allowed me to meet some great
people for sure
so James home who's actually who's our
web designer for long now and was on
this trip and was very uh was helping
along the way he's watching online
tonight
um but he's asking um
how you mentioned how critical the three
seconds is uh
can you say a little bit more about why
well I really felt like when I uh I
animate things in Photoshop and I use
that sort of create a frame animation
tool
um and so I try out different timings
um and it's really about like I try to
read it as if I've never seen the thing
before like this present moment used to
be the unimaginable future and I try to
see like oh did it turn off too soon
before I got you know through the whole
thing so for me it was really about
creating enough time for someone to read
it but then not lingering too long for
them to be like and you know attention
is lost
um so that like then almost as soon as
they're done reading it you know it
switches so it's a lot of play and I
think for this specific sign I was kind
of always between like two and a half
and three seconds and I felt like it was
better to give people a little more time
than to you know have not as much
so yeah that
that's the gist of it I guess we have a
question
Liz Beth and a shout out to Texas when I
moved here from Dallas seven years ago
so
um on time and just since the last
couple years I wonder does you know an
artist just you know what you
experienced and how you went inside and
any expression during the last two years
we've really been in different spaces so
I made this present moment in 2019 right
when I was in Portugal I think my my
exhibition opening there was in May of
2019 and then I came back to the United
States and made the second edition at
the end of 2019 maybe September October
and then
[Music]
um
and then of course 2020 happened and
everything shut down and I didn't
actually make art at all
um during the lockdown
um I live in a part of Texas where
everyone has Lawns and I had a lawn so I
my quarantine project was ripping out
all my grass and planting like a Zero
Escape yard and it was amazing to spend
time just like with my hands in the dirt
but
uh in 2021 I had an exhibition opening
in Dallas and that was when I made that
steel sculpture with the word future
removed
um so that I actually titled the
unimaginable future still inspired by
Stewart's quote but it was very much
related to my experience during the
pandemic the way that you know my
calendar was so full and then everything
was just wiped like a slate clean right
um so actually just like cutting those
letters out of the steel and I didn't
talk about this in the presentation but
that sculpture is made out of rebar
which you know is used to cast different
like architectural or infrastructural
elements in concrete and the larger
sculpture that creates that sort of
sense of perspective is actually tied
together with wire the same way that
they tie those kinds of architectural
elements together before they cast them
but
um ultimately like the future is a void
and this whole sculpture is tied
together in such a way that like
something like it was supposed to become
of it and then didn't
um so that was sort of my response to to
that time yeah
uh just a bibliographic note
um
it might probably be Gary Schneider's
last book of poetry the title of the
book is this present moment oh because
it really got to him apparently
and I have to say that
the event of that
line in the book
becoming a piece of art that is worth
climbing to the top of the mountain to
show it against a landscape I would say
it was pretty unimaginable
so thank you for that moment
thank you
do you have a shot of the Kilimanjaro
thing oh I think so it was kind of you
had to use a different technology than
neon in order to hike it all the way up
true I used LED neon for this one and
this is just an iPhone shot so
um the the shots with the you know DSLR
camera will get more of the stars and
stuff like that but
um it was a seven day climb so we set up
the sign at every Camp along the way
um what was the highest elevation you
got the 4600 meters meters sorry yeah
awesome and what's your next project
going to be uh well I really hope to do
more with this so this
and satsya is uh sort of like a renowned
mountain climber he's climbed all the
world's tallest mountains including
Everest like 12 times or something
um but I asked him like what kind of
State of Mind do you have to be to climb
a mountain like that and he said like
you have to be the mountain you can't
see it as an obstacle
so um so that's what inspired this and
we hope to and you know that inspired me
to think about environmental personhood
um which is you know has has been
a way of thinking for indigenous peoples
forever right to think about elements in
the landscape as our kin but it's
something that is kind of gaining
traction right now and recently the um
the country of New Zealand declared a
mountain a person a legal person right
and these things are happening more and
more
um and so I like to think about
um
that sense of personhood of when you're
on this mountain so we hope to take this
to more Mountains long story short
I very much like a mountain being a
person than a corporation which is what
we have exactly right I want to thank
you so much thank you thank you it's so
amazing thank you very much
foreign
[Music]